[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a new year and that means we're
back with some new games we're halfway
through January now and some of the
bigger titles are starting to drop
here's what you can look forward to this
week gravity rush 2 is zooming on to the
ps4 and that means a bigger map and more
missions new gravity styles let cat move
faster jump higher and slam harder than
ever before couple this with new cities
and destructible environments and you've
got yourself a playground where you can
break buildings and bridges not just the
rules of physics and of course there are
plenty of big boss battles to challenge
as you zip around we give cats new
adventure a 9 out of 10 so consider that
a strong endorsement for when it
releases on friday january twentieth if
you want to keep the action going check
out fate extel a-- the umbral star you
can create your own custom character
then command an army of servants as you
battle huge waves of enemies your
servants can be pulled from eight
different classes including archers
Lancers and berserkers you can team up
with servants for powerful combo attacks
or let them change into elemental forms
like fire and snow fadec stella released
in Japan last year but it's coming
stateside on the 17th the valkyria RPG
games continue with valkyria revolution
this entry is considered separate from
the main series and it trades the
real-time strategy of European Wars for
real-time RPG gameplay in the fictional
region of Jutland separate or not you'll
still need to be very calculating in
battle as your characters can
permanently die now carrier revolutions
theme is depth so don't expect an easy
time as you wage war against the Empire
of Rus it's coming to xbox one ps4 and
Vita on the 19 speaking of strategy the
next outing from developer calypso is
urban Empire it's not just about
building a city it's about controlling
it each game takes place over more than
200 years moving from the mid-1700s
Industrial Age through the modern day
planning the city is only the first step
as you'll have to fight to stay in power
as it grows over the years you can rule
as one of four families each with its
own line of successors you can start
building on PC on the 20th there's one
more RPG dropping this week and it's a
big one Dragon Quest 8 journey of the
cursed king debuted on ps2 more than a
decade ago and now it's been shrunk down
for the 3ds just like the name says your
journey begins when Kings Road is turned
into a troll and cue the massive
adventure that you could sink like 200
hours into it's pretty traditional but
dragon quest eight does introduce the
tension system which lets you skip a
character's turn so you can do more
damage the next round if that sounds
like your thing you can start the
journey on the 20th and those are the
big games will be playing this week
remember release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change new releases has officially
kicked off for 2017 so I'll be back next
week with more games see you then
you